un an je m'ennuie je m'ennuie vous êtes
là je suis bien content de vous voir
je suis tellement sol je m'ennuie je
m'ennuie c'est affreux non vous savez il
ya un mystère dans l'île aux enfants un
mystère vous savez ce que c'est beney je
vais vous raconter
voilà depuis ce matin je suis là et je
n'ai vu personne
personne n'est venu jusqu'au kiosque
c'est terrible je comprends pas françois
et sabrina c'est normal ils sont partis
à la ville et et ils m'ont demandé de
garder le kiosque je crois qu'ils vont
être contents de moi mais j'aimerais
tellement qu'il revienne je m'ennuie je
m'ennuie c'est affreux moi j'ai une idée
si si je vous chanter ma chanson un
d'accord non pas au miracle
[Musique]
avec des chansons et hop imagination je
me sens maintenant au prix de 30
[Musique]
le soyez terrorisés je suis le monde
ribéry
je m'appelle casini
la bombe couleur orange
[Musique]
et je sais jouer de la musique
je suis l es smalling amis
et me la glace aux anchois c'est
pourquoi c'est mon droit avec une
chanson un peu d'imagination
je vous emmène dans notre it is not be
du bonheur tranquille
[Musique]
ces couleurs rencontrer ne soyez pas
terrorisé je suis le monstre qui fait
rire
[Musique]
j'ai une machine est venu parce que je
mange
bluebeam bullguard mais je n'en sais ça
m'a gêné la campagne j'ai vu un leader
en khâgne au cinéma le 4 e 3 cet endroit
[Musique]
chansons
imagina
[Musique]
notre ici bas
10h38
ils font des rondes
2 soyez
ats
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
[Musique]
casini vous avez vu personne n'est venu
je suis toujours tout seul je sais pas
moyen il ya peut-être eu un tremblement
de terre un non non mon bel étalage
serait tombé un tremblement de terre
pomme toulouse 1
alors je sais pas or peut-être peut-être
une tornade
non non mais pourquoi cette personne ne
vient casimir qu'est ce que c'est il ya
quelqu'un qui est là c'est moi ce soir
mais dis donc aisé mire qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en france moi j'ai eu peur
le soleil pas que s'il ne fallait pas me
dire qu'est ce que tu as fabriqué depuis
ce matin je suis sale ici personne n'est
venu et ça t'étonne ouais mais dis donc
aisé mais regarde ma soeur quoi avec
toutes les pancartes la hawaii alors là
plus personne n'a osé s'approcher et
c'est pour ça que tu rester tout seul
quasiment ah bon mais oui c'est beau
c'est aux eaux
quasiment